after weeks of build-up ukraine says it
has launched a counter-offensive to
retake territory seized by russia in the
first weeks of its invasion
officials in kiev said their forces have
broken through moscow's defenses in
several areas of the front line near the
city of reson
as the pushback got underway the eu
agreed on launching its own new mission
to provide additional military
assistance to ukraine so we're asking
today ukraine counter-offensive can kiev
push the russian army back
[Music]
welcome to to the point it is a pleasure
to greet our guests marina henka is
professor for international relations at
the berlin-based tatty school and she's
also director of its center for
international security
and a warm welcome back to the program
to christoph von marshall he is
diplomatic correspondent for the berlin
daily detagger spiegel
and nick connolly is dw's ukraine
correspondent he's been covering the war
on locations since it began
let me start out by asking all of you to
give us your take on what's actually
happening on the ground because we
haven't been getting a lot of
information or
images coming from the region around her
son so nick what are you hearing are
officials in kiev giving us accurate
reports
in terms of both the counter offense of
having started and also having broken
through russia's front lines uh and how
would you assess the potential they're
keeping very quiet and they said that
they will keep quiet until they have
kind of concrete results so i think
there's not much sense expecting detail
from those official speakers um we are
seeing lots of images on social media of
explosions of you know things we've seen
in recent weeks but just being
intensified so the ukrainians really
using their high-tech western weapons to
destroy russia's logistics to go after
weapons depots to try and really knock
out those bridges across the nipro river
to basically trap the russian troops
around question on the west bank of that
very very wide nepro river i'm still in
touch with some people who have stayed
there who haven't left and they are
basically not leaving their houses they
are staying put having previously lived
in a situation where it was basically
every evening artillery kind of fire
around 9 10 p.m it now seems to be
pretty much all day and the people there
are just sitting put and hoping that
this kind of passes them without too
much in the way of devastation for the
civilian population although officials
in kiev has have actually just said that
people should be leaving uh that they uh
at least before the cold war gets the
cold weather gets there i mean that's
definitely been the call along to
encourage people to leave but the
question is how so now some the safest
route has for now until now been through
russian annex crimea and then people
have been traveling often extraordinary
lengths through crimea through russia
georgia turkey to get to ukraine
controlled territory the more direct
route to ukrainian control territory was
basically unmarked there was no kind of
corridor people were
reporting being also basically ransomed
by the russian troops you know them not
letting people leave with cash and other
valuables
and often getting very dangerous
situations so it's a pretty precarious
situation and i think the people i've
been talking to are saying they feel
safest in their sellers
marina the russian defense ministry has
actually now acknowledged that a
counter-offensive has begun but it says
it quote unquote failed miserably and
that ukrainian forces have sustained
heavy casualties just russian
disinformation or or what are you
hearing what i'm hearing is that the
morale is very high among the ukrainian
troops very strong fighting spirit that
they're also counting on the local
population the ukrainian population that
actually had an active resistance to the
russian occupation so they're counting
on on them to deliver
intelligence on russian positions in the
city
and that overall that the ukrainians
really think that they can you know at
least push forward
this is also very important from a
political point of view they want to
signal to western supporters to nato to
the united states that they can take
back territory and that they can win
this war exactly and i want to come back
to that point uh in a moment christoph
why is he sun strategically and also
military important what's the
significance of the fact that the
counter-offensive begins here near
hassan well first it's the location at
the
riverside of the nepalese very broad
river and then generally it's about
getting the south of ukraine back and
this is the region with all the ports to
the black sea that is very important not
only for corn to export which we have
heard but but generally the ukrainian
economy needs access to ports in order
to function and
at the moment most of the ports are
blocked by russian troops or taken
and occupied so this is strategically
important now the third theater we at
the beginning of the war six months ago
we saw the battle of kiev then after a
few weeks it changed to the east to the
occupied territories in eastern ukraine
and now the south becomes the main
battle
field and it's important for kiev to
show as the title of this
program that they are able to push back
it's a additional question whether they
will be able to push out the russians
i'm not so sure about that but pushing
back is important to give signals that
it makes sense uh to deliver weapons to
you
also have symbolic emotional
significance uh for ukrainians well
definitely because it's the first big
ukrainian city that was taken by the
russians at the beginning of this war
and there was also a lot of seemingly
failure failures on the part of the
ukrainian security services uh senior
ukrainian officials cooperating with the
russians um some of the bridges leading
from crimea had been mined in the run-up
to the war but then suddenly when the
russians appeared those mines were gone
um presidency has fired several top
security officials who are responsible
for that region so there's real um i
think kind of bad blood and you know a
feeling of shame among lots of high
officials in ukraine that they weren't
able to kind of root out these
collaborators in the lead up to this war
so i think there's definitely that need
to kind of show some successes to the
population but also this is a reachable
and attainable goal this is a quite
comparatively small chunk of territory
all on the right-hand side of the nipro
river so you know compared to trying to
take all the south back this is
something that is easily definable and
we've heard reports that the american
military advisers to ukraine had
actually pushed
for the ukrainians to
limit their ambition and to really focus
on kind of more attainable goals rather
than trying to do too much on too many
fronts
hefson was in fact taken as mentioned in
the early weeks of the war as events
were moving very fast but deadlock soon
set in success in retaking hassan could
break a long stalemate during which
neither side managed to make meaningful
territorial gains
the goal is to recapture lost
territories the battle in the kerasan
region has begun
seen here pictures of its preparation
kiev reports that some villages have
already been liberated
if the russian military wants to survive
now is the time for russian soldiers to
flee
to go home
if the occupiers are afraid to return
home to russia then let them surrender
we guarantee them compliance with all
geneva convention norms
in recent days russia had stepped up its
attacks on ukraine
shelling slovyansk and kharkiv in the
east of the country
residential areas were also hit with
many houses completely destroyed
according to british intelligence putin
had hoped the intensified attacks would
tie down ukrainian troops in the east
weakening the counter-offensive
in the south
but that plan appears to have failed
the ukrainian counter-strike has begun
can ukraine win this war
marina that's a 64 million dollar
question what would you say
well um the big advantage of the
ukrainians is that they have very modern
weapon systems now
and so you know why are they superior to
what the russians have well it's
actually because they're precision
guided they can hit from a very long
distance weapon depots and
russian military positions
the russians used to have a lot of
weapon systems and also a lot of
ammunition but basically they're
shooting blind
and
as long as the west delivers those
weapons and as long as the ukrainians
can make use of them so you're trained
to use them and this is what you
mentioned also before the eu mission to
train them i think ukrainians have a
real shot at you know like at least
pushing them back pushing them out is a
harder question but pushing them back
and here actually that's also one of the
successes of the sanction regime because
russia cannot build those really high
modern weapon systems right now because
they require microchips and this is one
item that where they really rely on
u.s imports or from south korea from
taiwan the quality of the chinese ship
is much inferior so yes ukraine you know
has to a certain degree a chance but you
know of course there's a massive
dependence on the imports from the west
and so the big question is will we
continue supporting ukraine and we're
going to come back to that later on but
let me ask uh a few more questions about
the counter offensive itself nick what
would have to happen strategically for
this counter offensive to succeed for it
to become a major step toward ukraine
winning this war
well i mean i think you know
firstly they're trying to knock out
those russian communications across the
nipro river so just kind of cut off the
garrison and katson from supply lines
from crimea from places further east so
that is kind of a crucial uh target and
it seems like the bridges there are very
severely damaged and the russians have
to use ferries pontoons across very wide
rivers i wouldn't want to be on those
ferries you know they move very slowly
of a very wide river they are sitting
targets and you know the ukrainians
thanks to american intelligence see
basically everything that the russians
are doing there and the distances really
aren't that big from those ukrainian
front positions um i think it's also
about um ukraine getting enough
ammunition for these highmars rocket
artillery systems i think with that even
that is a picture of uh the launch of
one of those systems um up till now
ukraine has had to really really judge
very carefully when they use these
high-tech weapons but they just weren't
getting the numbers that they were
asking for in terms of uh you know
refill from the american side now we've
had reports even from russian telegram
channels saying that the ukrainians are
using those highmars systems a lot more
liberally seemingly are not having to be
quite as economical where they're using
using them even against personnel
against russian troops in trenches
rather than just against kind of high
value targets so it does seem like
ukraine now at least in this part of
battlefield is somewhere closer to
parity in terms of weapons and is not
having to kind of play kind of on the
back foot kind of catch up as it has
been in other places kiev nonetheless uh
kristoff has been doing some expectation
management in terms of the timetable
saying that progress is likely to be
slow
to what degree is ukraine under time
pressure here we've got cold weather
coming i mentioned it earlier and also
putin is planning to hold a sham
referendum in the south to try to create
a justification uh for the occupation
does that mean uh does that mean that uh
in a sense kiev's got his back up
against a wall when it comes to timing
timing is important and there's an
interconnection between timing inside
ukraine
timing within the weather zones timing
with western countries and the
willingness to supply further aid
so they have to show some military
success in order to keep up
the willingness not only of the
governments but of western society
societies to support this type of policy
here in germany we are now talking about
a winter winter when people might be
freezing
in homes because there's not enough gas
or whatever or it's so expensive and
that could
decrease the support the political
support
that
western countries still
still want to give ukraine the weapons
to push back the russians and even maybe
at some point to push them out of
occupied territory so if there are no
signs of success
then the western willingness in the
societies to say yeah it's worse to to
fight the war with russia and to support
ukraine
would decrease and i think that is the
most important
factor marina let me before we we drill
deeper on that let me ask a bit about
the russian side of all of this russia
has now said that it could reinforce its
troops to 130 000 in january yet putin
has avoided either
general mobilization or conscription why
is that what's going on well it shows
that actually this war isn't as popular
as russian wants it to be a general
mobilization would require that putin
says this is a war we are at war russia
is at war and you know then he can
justify a full mobilization of the
country but in russia this war de facto
war so called a special military
operation and so he tries
you know with all means to somehow you
know like get to that stage of war and
it shows that you know he's afraid to
take that step
but you know um i'm very skeptical that
he can actually reach the target of 170
000 new troops and there are various
techniques he uses so for example he
tries to incentivize conscripts so that
they sign up for a permanent or like a
more permanent contract in fact
apparently some coming from prisons
convicted felons
are being recruited that's what u.s
intelligence
exactly reported also they try to get at
those
mercenaries right the wagner group tried
to integrate them in the russian army
but the big question is when we talk
about defensive positions and offensive
position and to have a successful
offensive you need to have a troop
advantage of you know a ratio of
three to one meaning the ukrainian side
needs three times more troops than
russia and or you know like if russia
wants to keep its defensive position it
needs to have this troop advantage and
that's why the true question and how
many soldiers are there is so critical
on both sides by the way nick what are
you hearing about russian morale
we heard marina say that
moral among ukrainian troops is quite
high perhaps you can confirm that as
well but what about on the russian side
i mean definitely this is you know
incomparable the ukrainians are fighting
at home they know why they're fighting
and also in a way vladimir putin's made
it easier for the ukrainians because he
said before this war that his basically
his goal is to get rid of this country
to end ukraine as an independent entity
so they know what they're fighting for
they're fighting for the existence of
their country um we've had lots of
reports from at least ukrainian sources
of russians being pretty eager to be
taken prisoner to get away from their
own commanders um the situation
particularly bad with people who've been
forced to fight people from donetsk and
luhansk who are often treated much worse
and given the easter egg from eastern
ukrainian
regions that have been under de facto
russian control since 2014 and these
people are they are sent in units that
are controlled by these quasi republics
and they are much worse supplied in
terms of equipment in terms of finances
and they are often sent to the most
dangerous parts of the front lines and
there are reports there of you know
mutinies of
the troops often using violence against
their own commanders and a lot of
tensions some of that may be ukrainian
propaganda but it does seem you know
there are videos of families in donetsk
trying to prevent their men being
conscripted going to the government
offices demanding that their sons be
sent home so i think there is a real
real problem there
just remind us because of course you
have been reporting on the ground and
again and again you've emphasized in
that reporting how bloody and cruel this
conflict uh is can you just uh
give us a sense of what you've seen in
these months i mean beginning of the war
we were in kiev and we were hearing the
artillery fire in places like buchen
european that we all then later saw
images of the extraordinary violence
used towards civilians there um we
couldn't get there it was we were
basically at a bridge that had been
destroyed we were looking across seeing
the artillery fire see people desperate
to get out
i remember standing at this destroyed
bridge and people carrying their
grandmother on a stretcher across the
destroyed bridge um while the artillery
fire was going on people were losing
their lives while trying to get out and
then obviously once uh it had been
retaken by the ukrainian forces seeing
the devastation seeing what those
russian troops had done there seeing you
know pools of blood just kind of on you
know where basically you know at every
turn um
the mass graves there i think the
scariest thing for civilians is just
quite at least in the early months of
the war quite how unpredictable it was
you know the front was moving a lot of
the time it's very difficult if you're
not experiencing these things to
understand where the artillery fire is
coming from
what direction it's going in so people
were just living in a kind of permanent
sense of high alert but on the other
hand it's strange enough people are
often very very unwilling to leave their
homes until it's often too late so time
and time again hearing stories of people
losing their lives or people trying to
help others evacuate being wounded
because people just refused to believe
that this was going to touch them until
basically the fire was kind of within
within view of their houses
in a word if russia is now going to
resort to more mercenaries to convicted
felons would you expect uh the cruelty
and the the
possibility of war crimes to rise i mean
i think that's definitely what ordinary
ukrainian citizens expect uh they are
um often you know pretty you know
desperate to get to ukraine control
territories you know whatever the price
may be um and and a lot of people are
just hunkering down and staying at home
and trying to avoid leaving you know
home as as you know do that as rarely as
possible there really is no kind of
clarity on what the rules of engagement
are for civilians in this conflict so
all of you have mentioned how crucially
important western weapons are to
ensuring that this counter-offensive uh
can make progress and it's become
something of a mantra in kiev as well as
among ukraine's friends in the west if
putin is to be defeated western weapons
need to keep coming the eu appears to
have heard that call shortly after the
war began it took the unprecedented step
of offering 500 million euros in direct
funding for military assistance and now
member states including germany say
they're ready to do more
sending german heavy weapons into
conflict zones is no longer taboo
chancellor olaf schultz speaks of a
turning point
ukrainian soldiers are to be brought to
germany to learn how to operate a gepad
tank
berlin plans on sending 30 such
anti-aircraft tanks plus ammunition to
ukraine
we will offer ukraine economic financial
political humanitarian and also military
support
we will maintain this support for as
long as is necessary
and after much back and forth the
so-called ring swap has also been
finalized germany will supply the czech
republic with leopard 2 battle tanks
in return prague will send soviet-era
t-72 tanks to ukraine where ukrainian
soldiers can operate them without
instruction
can modern western weapons push back the
russian army
we put that question question straight
uh to christoph but also couple it with
a question about german support because
germany has been criticized for being
slow and equivocal in its follow-through
on its on its promises of support is
that changing it is changing but not
fast enough and not uh
it's it's not it's too little too late
if somebody is saving uh the uk
ukrainian army it's certainly not
germany it's certainly not european uni
union it is us mainly and the british
and somehow from poland and baltic
baltic states and that is of course a
little bit of shame the change came far
too late
schultz
chancellor was not so sure about the
public support in in germany there's
always this
idealism that we should come to a
political agreement that this war should
be ended by negotiations but the
situation on the ground is a
precondition for any talks and i think
ukraine needs to to regain territory in
order to that they have a real chance in
at the negotiation table supposedly
germany's hesitancy also has to do with
with fears on the part of the chancellor
and others that if
germany and the eu go too far in
delivering heavy combat weapons that it
could pull nato into what they what
sometimes refers to as world war iii
i don't think that that is
a fair uh assessment uh that i mean
germany is not delivering enough that
this is a real danger for vladimir putin
germany is a weak point in the whole
political discussion i mean if if a
putin would like really to threaten the
west he should threaten the united
states because they are delivering the
weapons which which are needed and the
european union
provides money and that is good that
they are providing money but they don't
provide weapons because european union
has no weapons on stocks they just can
give money to ukraine and if you compare
if if you say uh well another half a
billion euro and that is not very much
uh for for days or weeks of war
the west has to deliver weapons in in
the range of
several billion dollars every month and
not just um millions marina is that
right
yeah that's correct and i i also agree
uh with mr marshall because so you know
germany thinks that it can it's really
the the kind of like the decider in this
war but you know like if russia wanted
to escalate it would escalate um because
the americans um are you know like uh
doing steps that you know like are
perceived from the russian side as
escalatory so germany is not you know
like the the linchpin in this this
battle can i just ask briefly if you
would how convinced you are that europe
and germany are going to keep the
support coming even as we move into a
cold and tough winter where gas supplies
are dwindling where energy prices are
soaring and governments are having to
give out billions in relief packages
i'm pretty convinced that germany will
make the right decisions but it will not
be wholeheartedly it will be always um
with a lot of hesitancy and also that's
send signals that send signals to the
united states but also sometimes maybe
even more importantly to our eastern
neighbors that's poland that's the
baltic states and i think they will come
out of this war thinking can we really
trust germany can we also trust france
going forward also in a european and an
eu context and i think that's the real
conclusion of that of that debate let me
just very briefly ask us to talk a
little bit about the bigger picture and
i want to tie that to another uh offer
that we heard from chancellor schultz
this week on a trip to the czech
republic he called for a new joint air
defense system for europe to enhance the
continent's security
nick do you think that
that would significantly improve defense
and deterrence for europe as a whole if
russia's imperial revanchism sets its
sights on targets beyond ukraine
i mean i think it's a question also of
the timelines when this is actually
going to happen i mean we've seen lots
of fairly seemingly impressive
announcements in terms of defense from
the chancellor schultz and from the
german establishment but when you then
dig a bit deeper you kind of ask
yourself is this going to be realistic
within the next five years i think
there's still no way around nato i think
the american deterrent is still crucial
to all of this and for now you know we
saw germany announce 100 billion euros
in extra spending for defence but still
if you look at the years beyond that and
take these hundred billion out of the
equation germany is still not planning
to reach the two percent of gdp
contribution you know to its defense uh
so i i'm kind of hesitant and i think
lots of people further east in poland
and let alone ukraine are still very
skeptical that you know
germany and france are willing to step
up and to basically look after their own
security you know without that american
support even though america you know is
very tied up in in the pacific
christophe um staying with the big
picture mikhail gorbachev died this week
he was the author author of the vision
of a common european home and a europe
whole and free
did putin's invasion in february put an
end to that vision for good
i think even gorbachev was not really as
as he's seen in germany as a big
european peace fighter he wanted to
maintain soviet power the soviet union
and we were lucky enough that he didn't
shed blood in berlin and in prague and
in warsaw but he did it in lithuania and
latvia and so on so i think containment
is the main strategy we need and that
means europe has to contain russia
because the u.s might be
have all the hands full with containing
china
thank you very much thanks to all of you
for being with us today and thanks to
you out there for tuning in see you soon